US, JACQUELENE.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
ALSO, FOR THE FIRST TIME SINCE
THE WRITERS STRIKE ENDED,
FRED ARMISEN IS BACK WITH US,
EVERYBODY.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
AND FRED, I KNOW MUCH LIKE
HAPPENED TO ME, I'M SURE IT
HAPPENED TO YOU.
PEOPLE SAID, "OH, WHAT HAVE YOU
DONE WITH YOUR FIVE MONTHS OFF?"
AND I KNOW I DIDN'T DO MUCH, BUT
I ALSO KNOW YOU NEVER GO FIVE
MONTHS WITHOUT DOING ANYTHING
AMAZING.
AND I HEARD THAT YOU STARTED A
NEW WALKING TOUR OF NEW YORK
CITY.
>> Fred: I DID.
>> Seth: YOU DID.
>> Fred: YES.
>> Seth: NOW I KNOW THERE'S A
LOT OF WALKING TOURS OUT THERE.
HOW IS YOURS DIFFERENT, FRED?
>> Fred: I GO TO PLACES THAT
HAVE THOSE SORT OF -- THOSE PET
CARRYING BAGS, YOU KNOW?
LIKE FOR TRAVEL.
>> Seth: LIKE IF YOU WANT TO GO
ON A PLANE WITH YOUR PET YOU PUT
IT IN THAT.
>> Fred: YES.
SO, WE GO TO ALL THE SHOPS THAT
CARRY THOSE.
[ LIGHT LAUGHTER ]
AND WE JUST GO FROM, YOU KNOW,
JUST GO TO 23rd STREET, WE'LL
WALK UP TO 27th STREET.
[ LIGHT LAUGHTER ]
THEN UP TO 31st STREET.
>> Seth: SO NOW THAT'S
INTERESTING THAT PEOPLE -- I
FEEL LIKE NO ONE WHO VISITS NEW
YORK THINKS THAT'S A THING WORTH
SEEING.
>> Fred: WHICH IS WHY I STARTED
IT.
[ LAUGHTER ]
AND IT'S GREAT.
THERE'S SO MANY DIFFERENT KINDS.
THERE'S MESH ONES, THERE'S SORT
OF HARD CASES.
[ LIGHT LAUGHTER ]
>> Seth: AGAIN, THOUGH IT SEEMS
WEIRD.
LIKE, WHY WOULD YOU HAVE TO GO
TO ALL THE DIFFERENT STORES?
'CAUSE I WOULD ASSUME MOST OF
THE STORES HAVE THE SAME KINDS.
>> Fred: NO, NO, THEY VARY, AND
ALSO IT'S A WALKING DISTANCE.
IT'S A WALKING TOUR.
LET'S WALK.
[ LIGHT LAUGHTER ]
IS THE IDEA.
>> Seth: SO BASICALLY YOU WERE
TRYING TO FIND ANYTHING FAR AWAY
THAT PEOPLE COULD WALK, BUT NOT
SO FAR AWAY THAT THEY'D WANNA
TAKE A CAR.
>> Fred: THAT'S EXACTLY IT.
>> Seth: WOW.
[ LAUGHTER ]
AND JUST IN CASE, I'M ASSUMING
THERE'S A WEBSITE IF PEOPLE NEED
TO LOOK IT UP.
WHAT'S IT CALLED?